right
645 million
584
462 in standard form so let's tackle
this piece by piece so the first part we
have 645
million
645 million so let's think about that so
we have 645
645 but it's not just 645 we have 645
millions so we could view that as 645
times
times 1 million
one million is one followed by
six zeros so this piece right here is
this right over here that is 645
million and what is that when we write
it out if we were to multiply this out
this is equal to it would be 645 times
this one with six zeros behind it so
this would be equal to 600
i'll write it like this this is equal to
645
and then we have our six zeros one two
three
one two three that's just this part of
the number and i'm going to do it kind
of slow and do it do all the different
parts of the problem but once you get
some practice you'll find that these are
a bit second nature and you won't have
to go through all these steps you'll
just be able to write the number now
let's move on to the next part we have
584 let me write that down 500 and
actually let me write it like this
we have well right like this 584
thousand
584 thousand so let me write the
thousand so 584 thousand so it's 584
times
1000 and what's that going to look at so
that that's this whole part right here
so 584 times 1000 is equal to what
what's going to be 584
with three zeros behind it or you could
view it as 584 times the one and you're
gonna have three zeros in the final
answer so it's going to be 584
500
thousand
you have our three zeros at the end 584
3 0. so that's that part and then
finally
we have
462
400 462 and that's just 462 straight up
you could view it as 462 ones so then
you just have 462
which obviously equals just 462.
now our number is all of these combined
it is 645 million and 584 thousand and
462. so one way to think about it that
you could add these three numbers
so if we were to add them
if we were to add them we get
645 million
645 million
584
thousand
584 thousand
four hundred and sixty two
four hundred and sixty-two now i said
it'll become a little bit of second
nature to you in a little bit and the
way to think about that the easiest way
to think about that is millions will
have six zeros behind them thousands
will have three zeros behind them and
just regular numbers have no zeros
behind them so what you can do when you
kind of want to learn second nature
you'll just look at the 645
million so you'll write 640
and you'll kind of keep in the back of
your mind that you're going to have to
have
six more digits to the right of this and
then you say 584 000
and so then you have your 584
000 so then you write that down
584 000 keeping in mind that you're
going to need three digits to the right
of that and so if they didn't tell us
462 we would just put three zeros here
and that would also fulfill the six
zeros we need behind 645 million but
then they tell us
462 so we just write that right here
462.